ich muss wirklich sagen es ist ihr wäret
ihr seht schon wie ich den 7 es ist
wirklich so ein richtig cooler sieht die
nicht entdeckt habe hallo ich meine
lieben freunde und herzlich willkommen
zu einer minecraft pre release 11.8
zieht vorstellung von mir auf meinem
kanal heute morgen ich geh auf twitter
ich seh chip hat die 1.8 release
rausgebracht da denke ich mir natürlich
erstmal wahl stelle ich euch erstmal
vorne im kurzen video was da alles neu
gekommen ist cool bearbeitet dies dass
es hat total geruckelt er zwar noch ein
paar bugs drin und es ist noch nicht die
stable version sondern halt wirklich nur
ne prima ließ deswegen hab ich gedacht
okay mit der vorstellung von den ganzen
neuerungen warte ich noch bis die
stabile version raus ist die öffentlich
angekündigt wird und alles mögliche
damit gemacht wird die dann wirklich
auch in dem launcher gezeigt wird nicht
nur unter diesen snapshot versionen und
priorität sondern wirklich unter stable
version mit der vorstellung warten noch
aber ich habe mir gedacht komm generiert
schon die 1 punkt ab release raus ist wo
dingen zu gefährden die greenlight ende
seid neue blöcke neue mops und vor allem
meeres tempel habe ich mir und dieses
neue rändern das ist wohl die welt
bearbeitet sich so schnell wird so schon
geändert mainz kad gewimmelt habe ich
mir gedacht ich stell dich ein fachmann
zieht vor der ein paar geile sachen von
den neuerungen hinzufügt und zwar ich
muss wirklich sagen es ist ihr werdet
schon wie ich den zieht es ist wirklich
so ein richtig cooler sie die nicht
entdeckt habe also ich zeige ihnen euch
mal 5 3 454 05 78 71 86 96 0 6893 welt
erstellen die ganzen einstellungen lasst
ihr so ich weiß ich warum ich so gemacht
habe aber gut und zwar seht ihr schon
die s bahn einfach mal im dunkeln das
ist geil einfach unter wasser okay das
sollte eigentlich nicht sein aber wir
sind hier auf einer survival ins und ihr
seht schon wie schnell sich die welt
aufbaut alter das ist so geil wir haben
jetzt ein paar kleine inseln dass eine
dahin ist noch ein bisschen da sondern
eine ganz kleine und wir bauen auf einen
survival sieht das einzige was wir hier
haben sind ein paar bäume ein bisschen
sand und was wir hier unten haben ist
eisen wir haben hier vier eisen da das
ist das einzige eisenvorkommen - so eine
kleine höhle die kammer noch ein
bisschen runter graben eventuell stößt
man auch noch auf so ein paar blöcke so
seht ihr schon jetzt auch schon diese
neuen blöcke wie beispielsweise ende
seit ich glaube das ist die krankheit
ist das und man hat noch sendezeit oder
jeden fall ganz ganz viele neue blöcke
und da hinten wie diese inseln wenn ihr
diese andere etwas größere insel
anvisiert und dann einfach mal rechts
guckt können wir uns erst mal einen
trank ganz kurz geben und zwar einen
wert waren trank der nachtsicht gehe ich
mit meiner gegnerin viele von ok ich
habe sechs minuten mehr geht glaube ich
nicht und dann können wir hier ein
bisschen durchs meer fliegen was er auch
hallo mr
wieso habe ich keine nachtsicht wieso
habe ich keine nachricht button na egal
was ihr hinten auf jeden fall schon seht
ist ein wasser tempel
wir haben hier eine gottverdammte wasser
tempel das ist ein bisschen wie sehe ich
nichts mehr bewegt das nicht oder soll
ich mal ganz kurz die milch trinke ich
warte dann ist der effekt der eigentlich
ist er ja weg kehrt sich gar nichts
unter wasser jetzt gehe ich mir noch mal
ein
ich habe mich nicht getroffen so hell
wie sie geht es nicht wieso kann ich
nicht oder wasser gucken crazy egal ich
kann euch auf jeden fall noch so zeigen
wir haben hier nämlich wenn ihr auf der
insel seit und in richtung norden guckt
seht ihr hier einen unterwasser tempel
mit einer schatz kann man alles mögliche
alles mögliche was beim unterwasser
tempel dazu kommt dass für mox sind
das hier sind nämlich diese wächter da
unten seht ihr hier da moment passiert
sind die wächter die bewachen das ganze
wenn die jetzigen mob angreifende seht
ihr das schon da die schießen die mobs
einfach ab und töten die dadurch sind
alles mögliche und das ganze stelle ich
euch hat noch einen vorstellungsvideo
abfahren wollte überhaupt einen
zeitnehmer bitte mit dem daumen hoch
irgendwie ob wir das überhaupt wollt
also geht man daumen hoch oder
schätzungen kommentare wenn überhaupt
von vorstellungsvideo von mir haben
wollte
vielleicht wollte er gar nicht wollte
nicht und wir können hier so ein
bisschen durchfliegen haben wir
verschiedene räume wie beispielsweise
hier sind so schwämme man kann hier ganz
ganz viele sachen finden und vor allem
auch relativ schnell diesen raum und das
hier ist nämlich diese schatzkammer also
ich möchte einen noch nicht alles
vorstellen deswegen mache ich ja dann
eventuell dieses vorstellungsvideo hier
sind diese ganzen laternen durch das das
ganze erleuchtet wird hier sind acht
gold blöcke drehen das ist die belohnung
wenn man es bis hierhin geschafft hat
quasi weil diese teil auch relativ stark
sind und ja auch relativ viele darin
vorkommen
und es gibt auch um das mal ganz kurz
hier auch nochmal zu zeigen
ich glaube hier oben müsste einer drin
sein und zwar gibt es die guardians auch
an einer verstärkten formen
das sind nämlich diese großen wächter
oder bulgariens oder keine ahnung wie
die genau heißen und zwar möchte ich
euch wo ich habe schon böses und möchte
ich auch möchte ich euch von denen hier
auch nochmal einmal ganz kurz ein zeigen
damit ihr seht das wirklich auch so ein
relativ viele neue hinzugefügt wurden
was hinzugefügt wunder also die könnt
ihr auf jeden fall an treffen in diesem
sieht also um das ganze mal zum ende zu
bringen
dieses sieht verstellen das war's
eigentlich wollte ich nun zieht sagen wo
ihnen unter wasser tempel findet und wo
ihr halt die schatzkammer dann alles
möglich auch das ist halt wirklich in
zweifel zieht also da könnt ihr wirklich
mal die ganze einfach testen ihr nahe
ihren zügen und alles mögliche man kann
sich hier drin schon mal leicht
verlaufen
das ist das ist muss man schon mal so
sagen die sounds sind auch ein bisschen
eklig aber ich verstehe nicht warum ich
diesen raum finden wo man so ein großer
recht hat unter den wollte eigentlich
schon zeigen ja der sieht mich richtig
richtig gefährlich aus er ist natürlich
auch stärker als die normalen wecker und
er sieht richtig krass aus also der ist
richtig groß dass man mit mir vergleicht
jeder das ist schon gefährlich am ordner
und der verträgt auch einigermaßen was
also ihr seht schon hier dass das
ruckelt noch alles ein bisschen diese
premiere ließ ich hoffe dass er noch mal
besser wird alles richtig was ab und
das wars mit der zielvorstellung es euch
gefallen hat und eventuell märz
vorstellungen haben wollt dann schreit
seine kommentare oder wenn ihr eventuell
einen viel besseren zieht entdeckt habt
also wenn ihre enthält sagt okay kommt
der sieht es cool aber ich habe einen
entdeckt er ist viel viel cooler
dann schreibt zwar einfach dieser zeit
wurde mir von niklas glaub ich
zugesendet an meine mail oder in den
kommentaren hat dagegen geschrieben und
der letzten zeit ich weiß nicht mehr
genau
also wenn ihr mehr davon wollte und wenn
euch das gefallen hat dann schreibt
dokumente sieg dann schreibt viele
kommentare lasten daumen hoch da und
sonst würde ich sagen wir sehen uns an
alle allerspätestens im 1.8
vorstellungsvideo wieder oder einfach
morgen im anderen video oder weihnachten